Adie do you remember the day that you
asked Joshua to confront the
perpetrators and do you have any regrets
haha Idina Terry pertama Andy bellossom
and Joshua oh I didn't get the money man
black Cunha then Africa's Lama in
high-def insulin what to town do a
reboot tickety-boo on but it says the
new Tarakan Santos then say my sake -
Duke
tidak mungkin to Baltimore see just
mahram do mccammon and kataka tapi but
hidden here
sadly / - no condensation on current era
Brazil mr. Burton Rancho Megan para
Pomona um yeah I when I first suggested
to Josh whether I wanted when I first
told Josh where I wanted to meet the
perpetrators he said no it's too
dangerous and I was frustrated but then
when we found a way of doing it safely I
I'm very very glad we were able to do it
what made you trust Josh well how did
you know that he would protect you and
you'd be safe I Peyman what I did is I
my Joshua and by Joshua Hungary and Umi
IDs to slam up for us what I'm gonna
mean seppuku just was just what you got
Brenneman and Gracie Kuya
had to stop this just so I'm brandy
butter up the two into my own cup Dino
nice addresses her to her young son at
Abu Mohammed Pantera's Callie done it to
addressed to Harlem burn Isaiah
topically a desire Atticus I am not see
I'm not connect I could feel something
about Josh where that would that would
be protective and keep us safe but I do
have to admit that that Joshua is also I
had to talk about myself
Josh was also very very brave and in
fact the only person in Indonesia who
come to Indonesia who had the courage to
open this up in such an effective way
over such a long time and I sort of felt
that someone who has that courage and
the systematic way of going without
things would have the would would also
was clearly thinking about all the risks
and would be able to keep us safe going
back to the filming was there a question
that you wish you'd asked the
perpetrators that you did not ask or was
there something you would have changed
about the entire filming process
Malik Attica cover system rotten film
Prytania an trap and two chicken with
bamboo no young got some potato today
Lisa Masada Sam Peckinpah decided to a
toe apakah had heard upon lion trap
bagaimana process button fill a mini
young and other I mean you have a single
bhakti to summit banister in Kannada
para Baku a cantata pe2 other assets or
to Harlem tidak mungkin
boom-boom car at the market Rwanda para
praça young para aumentar we buy I am
Burton a de la cual Gary Bedell
Maracaibo no hito dresses for insanity
da Mosta Hill quality did a Bonaparte
Anya Canyon with a rock you can borrow
kiddo
there were so many questions I wanted to
ask at that time that I couldn't ask
because it just felt if how dangerous it
felt impossible given the situation
either of the perpetrator or their
families and it and and so it's odd to
think what would I have liked to ask
because I still remember the experience
and remember all the questions that I
wish I could have asked that felt like
impossible to ask her to dangerous tasks
at the time
Joshua I believe you said that it's the
function of art to make us look at our
most painful truths what truth is faced
about the look of silence I think
perhaps that first of all every
perpetrator in our in our history is a
human being and that that's something
already clear from my first film
actually but that here that until we
that the again and again in the look of
silence we here let the past be past and
survivors always say it out of fear
perpetrators always say it as a threat
which means the past isn't past it's
right there it's an open wound that's
keeping people afraid it's empowering
perpetrators to threaten and I suppose
if the film has any
perhaps it's most important message is
that every society everywhere in the
world
will be torn asunder by impunity and
form subtle insidious forms of fear
until we collectively find the courage
to stay still turn around look to the
past and acknowledge together what we've
done to each other and and have the
painful discussion how are we going to
then turn back to the future but finding
a way of living together where we can
make sure these things never happen
again
so when keeping with that if the act of
killing is a film about denial and about
lying to oneself to justify one's
actions
what is the look of silence a look of
silence is kind of a poem a kind of
backward looking poem highly dramatic
because there's never been a film where
survivors or confronting perpetrators
while the perpetrators are still in
power before this but it's a poem about
what does it do what does fear do to
human beings what does it do to have to
live for 50 years in fear and silence no
I think you'd said that you wanted to
keep your film from looking less
journalistic and and topical because you
felt that it would have a longer life
how did you how did you keep the film
away from that style that sort of
newsroom style well I don't think I was
trying to avoid a journalistic style in
order to give the film a longer life I
think I was simply I simply recognized
that I wanted the film to immerse you in
Oddie's family I wanted you to feel like
you are adi or your brothers Adi and his
parents or your parents your
grandparents and his children are your
children so then that sort of
counter-intuitively therefore by going
small by being very microscopic the film
would become much bigger and about all
of us it would become universal and the
way I did that was by finding a very by
thinking of the film as a succession of
experiences for the audience a
succession of tones of moods where you
feel the haunted haunted space in which
this family is forced to live the fear
or the silence the ghosts you feel it in
your body
and yes you might call that storytelling
but unlike a news story which presents a
world
they're here it's it's almost I've tried
to create a kind of physical immersive
experience so you know what it's like to
live in fear and the power of the film
comes not from thinking oh no look at
what these people are suffering out
there but rather oh yes of course this
is what fear would do to us and of
course actually we all live in fear in
some ways and of course this is about
all of us right so you said that a
cinema is a powerful tool for
intervention so with the look of silence
and the act of killing what resolution
has come
I wouldn't say any resolutions come but
the act of killing helped prompt a
fundamental change in how Indonesian
Indonesia talks about its past it's
raised awareness around the world of the
genocide but also led to discussions all
over the world about impunity especially
in post-conflict situations the look of
silence has entered that space
everywhere the act of killing went and
deepened and expanded that conversation
to be one about what happens about how
how urgently truth and reconciliation
are needed in the aftermath of mass
killings and how and in any form of
atrocity and how and indian indonesia
specifically the the look of silence has
screened thousands of times by upwards
of five thousand times it's distributed
by the government by the National Human
Rights Commission at the same time as
it's banned by another part of the
government the film censorship board
under with due to pressure from the
military and so we have this
extraordinary situation where a
country's grappling really urgently and
and intensely with the question of its
own past and that's a non there's no
resolution to that yet but the the
movement for truth justice and
reconciliation has been I think
profoundly activated and energized by
the film thank you thank you both thank
you